you know what's gonna happen in my own
my own home state of new york
on thanksgiving you always look forward
to it it's it's kind of the
mark the beginning of the christmas
season the thanksgiving day parade
the macy's thanksgiving day parade oh
i've got such wonderful memories
as a little kid waking up sipping hot
cocoa watching the macy's thanksgiving
day parade well it's not going to happen
not going to happen this year for the
first time in the 90-year history
of the macy's thanksgiving day parade
they're not going to hold it because
of coronavirus that's what they say
but it's not about coronavirus and it's
not about public health
bill de blasio back in july when
everyone was worried about the second
wave and coronavirus jumping up again
bill de blasio said yeah we're going to
cancel these gatherings we're in cancel
parades or whatever these kind of
similar peaceful gatherings
we're going to cancel in in room dining
we're going to cancel bars we're going
to cancel concerts we're going to cancel
every
peaceful activity where you can join
together and then he's asked
about the violent riots and the protests
and you know he says
those are okay what about protests if
people want to march down
5th avenue are they going to be allowed
to do so look wolf this is always an
area of real sensitivity if you're just
talking about
health we would always say hey folks you
know stay home if you can but
we understand at this moment in history
people are talking about the need for
historic changes i mean today
in new york city you know recognizing
the power and the meaning of the message
black lives matter which we did in front
of trump tower today
this is a historic moment of change we
have to respect that but also say to
people
the the kinds of gatherings we're used
to the the parades the fairs we just
can't have that while we're focusing on
health right now
the kinds of gatherings we're used to
you know all the peaceful gatherings
every single one of them we can't have
those
and we can't have those for 15 days
sorry i mean 15 months sorry i mean 15
years sorry i mean no end in sight
we can't ever have those again so long
as we're out of power or i guess they're
in power but
they're not in power at the presidency
they're not in power at the
senate they're only half in power of the
supreme court so sorry we can't have
those
until you give us all the political
power we want we can have violent riots
though and we're going to have a lot
more of them if you don't elect us
that's implicit that's what he's saying
obviously it's not about public health
unless the coronavirus can discern
between
a peaceful parade the you know the
macy's thanksgiving day parade
and violent rioters and mobbers and
marauders in this unless
you figure out ah okay we're gonna go
it's a republican we're gonna infect
them
oh no it's a democrat hold off virus
hold off fellow viruses
unless it can differentiate that way
then obviously this was never about
public health and de blasio admits it
he says look we've got to cancel all the
fun stuff that we all enjoy that's
peaceful and lets us live together
but this is a moment of historic change
what historic change
oh it's a power grab that's what i mean
historic change that's a code word for
a leftist power grab and so we're going
to exploit that
i hope you enjoyed this segment of the
michael knowles show and you should know
on september 28th
the michael knowles show will be moving
from the daily wire youtube channel to
the michael nolshow youtube channel
because that just makes sense doesn't
it's right there it's right there in the
name
there is a link in the description below
head on over
subscribe to the michael noel show
youtube channel ring the bell
you will never miss another video
[Music]
you